mais finalement je me demande ce que
vous êtes prête à faire par amour pour
un homme vous êtes prête à faire
beaucoup pour un homme
oui oui on va voir interview par amour
qu'est ce que est ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à vous déguiser en
elton john
oui oui avec les lunettes la perruque et
ouais ouais ouais
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
prendre de la drogue comme mais non et
non parce que j'ai j'ai fait pas aimer
un homme que me demande ça a longtemps
été quand même est-ce que par amour si
votre homme aime les rues basses les
botero est ce que vous seriez prête à
prendre 17 kg botero ses 117
moi je sais est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prêt t'embrasser cent fois les
chaussettes sales de votre mari oui oui
c'est bien est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête paramo a accepté
quelques petites infidélités mais juste
un peu non non mr un peu non non donc je
bats rien à faire même pas pas de
maîtresse tout ça maintenant
vous n'êtes pas par amour si ça le rend
heureux si vous l'aimez mais non mais
non
si vous voulez mais non mais moi j'ai vu
pas aimer un homme comme ça donc j'ai
pas d'accord pour vivre à trois avec la
maîtresses n'ont pas d'accord pour aller
dans les clubs échangistes avec la
maîtresse il n'y a rien à faire
na même par amour mais nord est-ce que
par amour
vous seriez prête à devenir son esclave
sexuelle
ça dépend d'un homme ne pas comprendre
ça dépend à sa rentrée nous ben oui ça
les bancs de quoi si vous voulez mais
vous avez vous demande ça je trouve que
c'est un peu une
l'interview stupide je me disais aussi
des scènes entièrement d'accord et quand
on s'aime on ne demande pas où on est on
est une esclave sans avoir besoin d'eux
mais pourquoi l'esclave puisqu'il ya des
choses que je sais c'est expliqué c'est
pas pour moi je ne marche pas comme ça
mais j'aime bien aussi et peut-être via
peut-être je veux bien tu peux être
soumise comme en 30 matchs en mai
appâté qu'il ya une chose décidé d'être
quelque chose c'est une chose alors ça
c'est un autre type de jeu et c'est
chose quotient un jus cocciante à la
salle ça peut être aussi drôle a pour un
moment mais c'est moi que j'ai dcid
d'accord quand tu veux